[Music]
my name is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
one of the things that gets people riled
up when discussing the Bible is purity
laws it's saying it seems you can't
listen to someone criticizing religion
for two minutes
before they start saying how stupid it
is that you can't weave linen and wool
together then they'll go on to say that
the laws in the Bible that which are
about washing and about latrines in not
having latrines in camp are just
misunderstood and primitive hygiene but
I honestly myself I find those laws to
be some of the most interesting and the
most important in terms of understanding
how the world works and how we interact
with what is around us and so I'm going
to explain them as much as possible when
we look at the creation story in the
Bible we notice that the world is mostly
made by two processes calling forth into
being
let there be and then separating beings
into clear opposites hevanddan earth
light and dark water and dry land and
then the plants they're separated into
species which are meant to reproduce
themselves according to their seed and
then animals are separated into
categories fish birds land animals etc
etc so it's both separation demarcating
the difference between things and and
it's also a form of unifying giving
clear identity so each separated thing
has a heart it has a seed of a principle
something which unifies it as a
phenomenon now you'll notice that this
process of creation is a cosmic version
of how we engage with the world just as
God in Genesis by speaking separated the
chaos and potential of the primordial
world into demarcated categories so too
we engage the indefinite potential of
phenomena and we both separate separate
and unify so so so so this pen let's say
this pen stands out is separated from
the field of phenomena
surround it surrounded it but it's also
held together as a pen you know it which
is not a self-evident thing because the
the pen itself contains an indefinite
amount of complexity it has a series of
constituents and each of these
characteristics contain a near infinite
number of micro variations within it so
so so as and so it goes but our mind our
experience holds the category the
category of the pen together as a
discrete unity at the same time it
separates it from the rest of the world
separating and bringing together so we
could call this the right hand and the
left hand of Christ
it's the logos as the Good Shepherd
which who both hold the flock together
but also chases away the wolves okay so
that's what the logos does all the time
and I've talked about this before so I'm
also going to link to some of those
talks in in the description so what did
this have to do with purity laws first
off it's important to notice that that
we play a part as mediators of meaning
in holding the real the realm of being
together let's say we must must
constantly preserve the consistency of
things if we want the world to to remain
coherent and and often that for our own
sake so for our own sake you know that's
why we don't eat feces right and yes
that is a question of Hygiene but this
process of keeping things integral and
separated is also why we don't want it
we don't want to drop our telephone in
the bathtub
or why we don't want to drop some
ketchup on a nice white shirt and those
are not about hygiene we reproduce this
action of logos when we shut our doors
lock our doors at night when we build
dikes when we wash our hands and that's
why we have men and women's bathrooms at
least for now and the bathroom question
is important because the bathroom is
related to purity itself it's a place
where you don't want confusion between
what is eliminated and
what is retained and so the bathroom is
is inherently the experiential anchor
let's say the ground level of the
importance of keeping things clearly
distinct but there are a million
examples of how we deliberately keep
things separate in order to avoid them
becoming confused so instead of seeing
purity laws as a form of hygiene it's
best to see it the other way around
hygiene is a limited form of a greater
process of keeping things separate
keeping preserving the integrity of
categories unduly mixture can
contaminate things to a point that all
you have is a grey sludge a kind of mud
that's useless for anything so for
example if you mix iron with a bit of
carbon you get steel which is stronger
than iron but if you mix it with too
much carbon then you get something
called pig iron and then it is useless
and we also do this conceptually we have
conceptual categories like mine and
yours like inside and outside emotional
ones like joy and anger and all of those
categories have to preserve a certain
level of purity in order for me to
operate so if the distinction between
mine and yours for example gets confused
then war will come of it and of course
there is never absolute purity and
that's really important because the
desire for absolute purity is called
pride and and and in the Bible and in
the Christian worldview it is the root
of all sin and we'll see that in the
biblical laws as well how that plays out
but we'll get to that later to begin
it's sufficient to say that there is a
need for a certain level of purity or
else at some point comes the flood of
chaos so I'm gonna look at a few purity
laws not the obvious ones like washing
rules but let's look at the weirder ones
so there are three actually four laws in
Deuteronomy 22 verse 9 to 12 which I
like quite a bit
verse 9 thou shall not sow thy vineyard
with two kinds of seed lest the fullness
of the seed which thou has sown before
fitted together with the increase of the
vineyard thou shall not plow with an ox
and an ass together
thou shall not wear a mingled stuff wool
and linen together thou shalt make the
twisted cords upon the four corners of
thy covering wherewith thou covers
thyself so these four verses are
actually a beautiful pattern so the
first verse the first law is about not
mixing two kinds of plants the second is
about not mixing two kinds of animals
together and the third one joins the two
first ones together and is about not
mixing plants and animals together for
clothing so now the pattern moves also
in a repetition of the the order of the
creation of life in Genesis in the first
in the first chapter of Genesis with
first the creation of plants then of
animals and then the question of how all
of that relates to human beings and the
final verse the one about twisted chords
has to do with the Sabbath the seventh
day of creation the day when God rested
at the end of creation so just like the
last day was a day of rest a day when
one should not work the final fringe of
the garment has to be not worked
that is not woven or tied and left alone
simply twisted together to act like a
buffer of chaos at the end of a garment
and this is this is echoed by the fact
that the the preceding laws insist on
the separate that in system the
separation of things are also about work
so planting seeds laboring the field and
weaving clothing whereas the fringe is
an ornament right it's a decoration it's
not a form of productive it's not a
productive object
and now for the meaning of the friends
they're similar cult similar traditions
and in all kinds of cultures about
leaving the fringe of let's say rugs
alone and other similar things and it
has to do with this idea of a rest with
death and with the idea of how to deal
with things the the final things that
don't fit I spoke a lot about this in my
video on Shrek so you can check it out
if you want to know more about about
that now although it does not say this
explicitly in the text in Jewish
tradition this this friend is called sit
sit I might not be pronouncing that
right and it has something in it
sometimes in in the past it has been
made exactly out of a mix of linen and
wool it's a very mix of linen and wool
that is forbidden a few verses earlier
so what does that mean the friend is the
margin-right those of you who have
listened to my talks will have heard me
discuss this quite a bit it's the edge
it's equivalent to the flood so the
fringe of the vestment represents the
buffer of chaos in between categories
and the chaos which surrounds the field
of being and some might this some might
find this this odd and and maybe a
stretch of interpretation but when one
is aware of the basic structure of laws
in the Bible one knows this to be the
case because it is a pattern which
repeats itself so for example we find
many places where the edge of a space or
the end of a cycle is marked with a form
of rest we saw it the week there's also
the Jubilee
there's also leaving the seventh year of
of laboring of fields for the field to
be left alone this idea that at the end
of something you have to leave things
unfinished but it's also in that place
is also a place of mixture so for
example if we compare the fringes on the
four corners of the vestments the
Israelites were supposed to leave the
corners
of their fields unharvested and so
unfinished and this leaving unfinished
was specifically so that the marginal
people and the foreigners or the
strangers among you could gather the
grain for their own use so for more on
this you can read the story of Ruth in
the Bible where these images the images
of the remainders of the foreigner feet
and all of these images of periphery are
brought together so coming back to the
purity laws mentioned one would ask why
why they do that I mean why would they
not mix wool and linen and then have
wool and linen in their fringe and the
reason like most of you will have
guessed by now is that these purity laws
are not just a bunch of stuff you need
to do but they are a pattern of being
they're trying to show you the need for
keeping things separate in general and
do it by reproducing their order in a
kind of cosmic image a microcosm they do
that by using the same pattern as in the
creation story so to attend to these
laws is a way of stamping in us as an
image of the world and ensure that the
world does not fall apart you have to
keep things relatively separate
identities boundaries categories clearly
demarked and then you must also leave a
margin where mixture and chaos is left
alone one of the Jewish interpretations
of why you should not mix linen and wool
together has to do with Cain and Abel
who both brought their sacrifice to God
one brought an animal sacrifice and the
other brought a vegetable sacrifice and
the result is that the mixture or
confusion ended up with the murder of
Abel you can take that further and see
how the life the life of
agriculturalists and though that of a
nomad or
bird those are two exclusive forms of
societies which should be preserved in
their particular identity so all right
so already as I'm stretching this out
one can see that these laws are meant to
keep the World Order and you might think
that I'm pushing it but think about how
we deal with rules let's say how we deal
with rules with children we don't just
tell kids that they have to be orderly
that doesn't accomplish anything what we
do for example is we tell a child to
make their bed in the morning make their
bed every morning you know or we tell a
child to wash their hands and when we do
that we're not just demanding a result
in the present but we're expecting that
the habit of making one's bed every
morning will create a mode of being
which will follow the child into life
and ensure that this child keeps his
life in order when when they become an
adult you know and so living such a
patterned existence the one described in
these laws might lead to a world where
people would not be tempted to grow
human organs in sheep or to grow ears on
rats or to create glow-in-the-dark
animals a world where we would avoid
creating sterile hybrid fruits and
vegetable or avoid something like CRISPR
which proposes an endless possibility of
monsters right it wouldn't it wouldn't
give people the desire to bring back the
woolly mammoth for example it would be a
world where mixing intelligence and
consciousness with machines would
immediately seeing suspect now you might
say that I'm pushing it I'm exaggerating
the extent of what these laws can have
that the ancients did not think in such
terms but I don't think so
for example for example in the ancient
flood traditions surrounding Noah's Ark
we have this notion that the Giants
which appeared at the end of that world
were a mixture of the Sun
of God and the daughters of men these
giants were said to have taught humans
all kind of technology and magic and one
of the traditions is that these giants
made many chimera that is monsters which
were mixtures of different animals and
this is one of the reasons for the flood
you see the flood is that very falling a
part of the dikes which hold things
sufficiently separate from each other so
that the world can continue to exist I
mean one vision of the flood could be
found in no longer holding things
clearly distinct from from each other
man from animal male from female child
from adult and the ancients knew this
very well so why don't we follow these
rules anymore
the rules about linen and wool
especially Christians don't follow those
rules now Christians still have purity
rules at least traditional Christians
baptism of course being the the the
prime one but also the liturgy in the
liturgy the priests will wash his hands
ritually we have the washing of feet
once a year but we don't have rules
about mixing
I mean nor do we have rules about you
know kosher foods and other rules like
that so how to make sense of that so I
wanted to come back to the notion of
wool and linen because it's one of the
most complete examples of all this and
it will help us to understand why
Christians don't follow these rules
besides the fringe there's another place
in the Bible where joining linen and
wool is not only permitted but is
actually mandated the priests in the
tabernacle the tabernacle is the place
where the priests would offer sacrifice
and where the Ark of the Covenant was so
the priests wore a linen undergarment
with a wool tunic the way the priest
wears his vestment possibly reproduces
what is forbidden in the laws but it
also reproduces the tabernacle itself in
the tabernacle a linen veil
was used to separate the the different
places in the tabernacle so the the Holy
of Holies from the holy place and then
the holy place from the outer court but
then the the tent itself the outer
covering of the tent was made out of out
of animal skins different types of
animal skins there was first a wool skin
then there was there's first a wool
covering and then a a a skin of Rams
hair which was dyed red and so you can
see that it gets coarser and coarser as
you you get out and then finally there
was the skin of an animal which we don't
know what it is and until now
you know scholars Jewish scholars
Christian scholars discuss stuff try to
find out what this unknown animal is and
for so it fits perfectly with this idea
of the fringe as being this question
mark as being this thing that doesn't
fit that isn't sure that is that is yeah
indeterminate let's say so in the temple
we see the law in action so not only are
the the plant and the animal separated
but they are used as separate tours they
are used to mark different spaces and to
contain different spaces Christianity in
one of its important facets is a
constant discussion on how things can be
both United and separate at the same
time for example it is very important
that Christ and the incarnation of God
is not a mix between God and man I mean
there were there were a century more
than you know we could say at least a
whole century of argument about how to
formulate this to formulate the fact
that Christ is not a hybrid not a mix
between God and men but the Church
Fathers really insist that Christ is
both fully God and fully man United
without mixture
in the same way God is a Trinity both
unity and multiplicity fully found in
God without confusion without the
confusion of persons I mean these seems
these might seem like contradictory
meaningless statements at first reading
but they're extremely important in the
vision of Christianity of how unity and
multiplicity need how they can coexist
and how and and therefore how the the
the highest non duality of being can be
expressed and the multiple and dual can
be expressed as well within the grand
vision of the infinite and it's really
important in how Christianity can be
universal and can join itself to all
cultures all the while preserving the
possibility of this multiplicity in
unity not dissolving all peoples and
identities into this uniform sludge and
so the symbolism of Christ will show how
it is since the logos is the origin of
the world how it is that he transcends
the problem of keeping things only
separate from each other some of the
symbolism of this is around Christ's
tunic which in the Bible is described as
being a tunic without seams that means
that that that isn't different pieces of
materials sewn together but it's rather
one woven piece completely so that's
really important this idea of this
disunity and we say say that this this
tunic without seams was never torn apart
and some of the earlier Christian
symbolism we see this is used for
example the the cloth there's a cloth
that is used to cover the host during
communion to cover the chalice in the in
the Eucharistic ritual and in some early
traditions of Christianity this was
meant to represent both the the pall of
Christ and so that you know the the
cloth which surrounded him as a body the
the cloth that surrounds a dead body but
it was also at the saint
I'm his tunic without seams and that
that cloth was made specifically out of
wool and linen together another way to
show this transcendence is in the very
old tradition of showing an ox and an
ass in the place where Christ was born
and this is interpreted in the Church
Fathers as being a joining of the Jew
and the Gentiles the joining of the the
the the inner people with the foreigners
and this obviously refers to those laws
in the Bible we mentioned earlier which
forbids yoking an ox and an ass together
so for those who want to know more about
this I've linked to some articles that
I've written on the subject in the
description but in the meantime he goes
to show that many aspects of religion
which can seem so strange and
superstitious at the outset are actually
a desire of formulating and not just
formulating in an abstract way but
participating fully in how the world
exists and are and also reflecting our
capacity to affect how the world exists
so I hope this was useful I'll see you
soon
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comment section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find a link to the patreon page
in the description below